hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
companion diagnostic and biomarker assay
development for
interrogation of liquid and solid tumor
biopsies
from rna scope and exosomes i'm kaley
bach of labyrinths and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by advanced cell diagnostics
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their site at acdbio.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenters
dr robert monroe
chief medical officer biotechnic dr
christopher bunker
senior director business development
advanced cell diagnostics
a biotechnic brand and dr michael
valentino
scientific director of companion
diagnostics within the business
development team at exosome diagnostics
a biotechnical brand
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr monroe you may now begin your
presentation
welcome to today's webinar on the
development of biomarker and companion
diagnostic assays
from rna scope to exosomes i'm rob
monroe
chief medical officer of biotechne and
i'll be joined by two of my colleagues
dr michael valentino
who's the scientific director of
companion diagnostics at exosome
diagnostics
and dr chris bunker senior director of
business development
at advanced cell diagnostics known to
many of you as
acd both exosome diagnostics and acv are
biotechny brands
and i'll be telling you a bit more about
biotechny in the next few slides
our goal for today's webinar is to
provide you with an overview of the
biotechnic technologies
that are currently being used by
biopharmaceutical companies
for the development of biomarker and
companion diagnostic assays
for their specific therapeutic programs
we plan to highlight the use of exosomes
and rna scope
rna and situ hybridization as companion
diagnostic platforms for biomarker
assessment and patient selection
with a specific focus on oncology
applications
before i pass the baton to michael and
chris for a more in-depth discussion of
these technologies
i'd like to first give you an overview
of biotechne since many people are not
as familiar with our parent company as
they are with some of the individual
biotechnic brands
such as r d systems and protein simple
so what is biotechne biotechny is a
minneapolis-based
life sciences company with over 2 000
employees
spread across 35 sites around the world
the company manufactures and distributes
a very broad range of consumables that
include antibodies
proteins amino acids small molecules and
in situ hybridization reagents
among other research tools as
highlighted in the pie chart the
consumables business comprises the
majority of the company's sales
but is also complemented by a growing
instrument business
specifically for automated protein
analysis as well as a services business
that's focused on the development of
assays for biopharma and diagnostic
industry partners
by the numbers biotechness brands
produce
300 000 products and six instrument
platforms
that are backed by 42 years of
manufacturing experience in over 600 000
publications
biotechnics core products include
antibodies
proteins amino acids small molecules
rna ish probes and exosome tools
these products support the company's
participation in a number of
exciting areas of the life sciences and
diagnostic markets
highlighted in this slide including cell
culture and gene therapy
tissue biopsy liquid biopsy and
automated protein analysis
the focus for today's presentation are
the technologies that support the tissue
and liquid biopsy approaches for
biomarker and companion diagnostic
assays
including the rna scope and exosome
analysis platforms
in thinking about biomarker and
companion diagnostic assays
i think that it's helpful to look at
this testing in the context of a cancer
patient's diagnostic journey
typically this journey begins with a
screening test
for cancer the most common screening
tests are mammography and colonoscopy
but they can also include traditional
serum amino acid based
liquid biopsy tests such as psa cea and
ca125 as well as emerging highly
sensitive approaches that examine
cell-free dna
circulating tumor cells and
extracellular vesicles such as exosomes
to look for evidence of cancer once a
cancer is suspected the patient
typically undergoes a biopsy or surgical
excision for a more definitive diagnosis
the resulting tissue is used not only
for diagnosis of tumor type
but also for further characterization
with prognostic and predictive tests
that provide information on a tumor's
expected behavior
and suitability for specific therapies
these latter assays that predict whether
a patient's tumor will be responsive to
a given therapeutic
as you know are called companion
diagnostics
following diagnosis and patient
stratification
patients typically will be monitored
going forward for evidence of response
to therapy
as well as potential recurrence with
various approaches including liquid
biopsy
similar to the liquid biopsy test used
for screening
the monitoring tests also leverage cell
free dna
circulating tumor cells and
extracellular vesicles to look for
evidence of recurrent cancer
along with genomic alterations including
those that confer
resistance to given therapies
exosome diagnostics and acd have
developed technologies to support
assay development at these three phases
of the cancer patient's diagnostic
journey
for example in the screening and
monitoring phases exosome diagnostics
exosome analysis platform provides for a
rich source of transcriptomic genomic
and proteomic information
for detection of low abundance mutations
an expression of specific rna targets
in the subsequent diagnosis and
stratification phase
acd's rna scope platform provides highly
sensitive and specific technology for
the assessment of biomarkers in their
spatial context
this allows the researcher or
pathologist to correlate biomarker
expression with cellular morphology
which is a major advantage over
traditional grained and bind molecular
assays
in this slide a potential use of
exosomes and rna scope
in the diagnostic journey of a
hypothetical lung cancer patient is
highlighted
initially the patient is identified as
having a suspicious lung nodule by ct
scan
and undergoes an exosome based lung
cancer assay for egfr mutations on a
blood sample
the exosome analysis leads to the
identification of an egfr
l858r mutation
as shown on the left the patient
subsequently undergoes a lung excisional
biopsy to remove the tumor
for definitive diagnosis and mutation
profiling
following classification is a lung
adenocarcinoma
the tumor is tested with an rna scope
technology called basecoat
for the presence of the egfr l858r
mutation
as you can see in the middle panel the
tissue based assay is positive for the
mutation
and correlates with the exosome analysis
as a result of the identification of
this mutation the patient is
subsequently treated with the targeted
egfr therapy
or lot nip which is an egfr inhibitor
shown to be effective in lung cancer
patients with this particular mutation
at some time following treatment with
her lotinib the patient undergoes a
liquid biopsy for monitoring purposes
in this case for evidence of recurrence
in the development of resistance
mutations
the exosome based test shows the
presence of an egfr t790m mutation
in the right hand panel in association
with the original
al858 r mutation
indicating that the patient has
developed resistance to the urlotinib
treatment
this resistance mutation is also
confirmed in a follow-up ct guided lung
biopsy
which shows the presence of both the
original driver mutation in blue
and the new resistance mutation in red
with the base copacity
hopefully this example highlights how
these technologies
can support testing across the cancer
patient's diagnostic journey
and with this overview in hand i'd like
to hand over the presentation to michael
for a more detailed look
into exosomes
thank you dr monroe for that
introduction and thank you everybody for
joining me today i'm very excited to
share with you
how we at biotechne and eczema
diagnostics in particular
are leveraging x's homes for the
development of biomarker
and companion diagnostic assays
so by way of introduction um liquid
biopsy and non-invasive
uh biopsies have been around for a
number of years and
and kind of exosomes are among the
newest players in that field
probably you should be well familiar
with modalities like cfdna
and circulating tumor cells and there
are
um some pros and cons
to these different modalities and so
what gets us really excited about
exosomes and why they're really a
growing force
in the liquid biopsy field is because
they provide a rich source
of information of uh from that patient
encapsulating the transcriptome and
proteome uh
of that individual and it provides
uh detection of low abundance rnas
because it's also more abundant and more
easily manipulatable
in terms of clinical trial support
than these other modalities like cfdna
and ctcs
and something that excites us at exosome
as well as our partners is because it
gives you the
active snapshot of these processes that
are happening
in the patients uh that you're
interested in
and so just a little bit about who we
are at exosome diagnostics
there are two commercial divisions i'll
mention but won't speak to very much our
diagnostics division
where we have launched our flagship
diagnostic
known as exodx prostate intelliscore or
epi
it's actually the world's first exosome
based liquid biopsy this one happens to
be based in
urine as the biofluid and it's a three
gene rna signature
that is used for risk stratification of
high-grade prostate cancer patients
and very exciting for us we've been very
active in great
uh uptake um along with reimbursement
like medicare
and recommendation in the national
comprehensive cancer network
guidelines and so this is really
exciting for us
how and for the patients that we're
helping along the way
i uh however will speak to our biomarker
services
our cdx division which is where i'm the
scientific director
in that team and so what we do for those
services
uh are customized projects based on your
clinical trial needs and focuses
and so we're very bespoke which is
advantageous to all our partners because
you can really
customize and uh focus on the things
that you
uh need for your programs and we span
kind of any stage along those programs
from early biomarker discovery which
i'll spend some slides talking about
next
into translational assays and then
designing developing and supporting
clinical assays as well
so just a little bit about exosome
biology
as mentioned exosomes will capture
the active transcriptome and proteome of
those patients
and so why that's really great and how
that differentiates us from other
modalities like cfdna
is because exosomes are released by all
living cells into biofluids and so
that's
health and disease and so you can really
listen in
on the signals and the communication
that are happening within those patients
and they play roles in the cellular
communication
in health and disease settings
and while exosomes are really small and
they carry snapshots
of what that parental cell is
communicating with when you take them
together
it actually provides a very big message
and so we do a lot of work in rna and
protein and for the
for the sake of time today we'll focus
on the rna work that we do
and i'm very excited to share with you
our biomarker discovery engine which is
built on a long rna-seq
pipe down pipeline analysis and why
we've
chosen to focus on long rnas is uh
probably if you're familiar with exosome
biology
the early rna work was all
largely focused on small rnas largely
technical limitations
uh and not biological limitations and
we chose to focus on designing and
developing from
from scratch a very sensitive and
powerful
uh platform to get at these diverse long
rnas
with the mindset being that many of the
actionable rna biomarkers
are mainly long rnas so a little bit
about what that pipeline looks like and
how it can be used
so it's been designed to accept inputs
from things like plasma serum csf urine
uh others are uh possible uh with
development
like saliva and assides fluid
i'll mention here also when thinking
about leveraging
us as uh as a partner for your programs
we also can run uh total tissue rna from
things like ffpe or fresh
frozen tissue in the same pipeline
we would do a total extraction and not
one of our proprietary
column extractions which isolate high
quality high quantity exosoma rna
but the library prep itself is actually
very amenable to
cellular rna modalities as well
and we have a number of panels
as well as whole transcriptome library
approaches that we could
apply to any of your programs i'll focus
on our whole transcriptome today
and what's most exciting for austin for
our partners is that this provides
similar diversity and detection to what
you see with
tissue and so if you're familiar with
any kind of tissue sequencing
you know you're going to see a lot of
protein coding genes
this chart here on the right is
capturing the number of genes detected
across these
rna biotypes and uh
while this may be challenging to see
because the words are really small
hopefully you can appreciate
that's because you actually capture wide
diversity of biotypes
captured in in these uh exosomal cargos
and the the biotype that is
by and large the majority are protein
coding mrnas
and you'll see other things like long
non-coding rnas which
are very relevant and interesting uh to
researchers
this chart here also demonstrates the
detection that you get from either 2ml's
being the light blue
or from half an ml being the dark blue
of
input plasma and so for this study
um a 2ml aliquot and a half an ml
aliquot was extracted through our
exolution column
subjected to our whole transcriptome
proprietary rna-seq
process and analyzed and hopefully you
can appreciate that it's very difficult
to discriminate
um the the data that comes from either
2ml
or half an ml and that's really because
you get
the same diversity of detection whether
using
2ml or as little as half an ml which is
very
empowering for our partners programs
very little plasma is needed to do
a lot of work and so what kind of
data what kind of information can you
expect from a typical
exosomal rna sample so the venn diagram
on the left
is capturing gene detection and
essentially
using as input either csf plasma serum
or urine and so the key part here is
across these four different
biofluids we can use the same core
technology
and then of course the same rna-seq
preparation and analysis uh pipeline
and and then compare the genes that are
detected from these different
biofluids and importantly these are in
the normal
sample setting as well
and so hopefully you can appreciate that
the largest number [ __ ]
is shared by all these different
biotypes but
there are still unique genes that are
are
detected in in those biofluid
compartments and so what that really
says is that
there are many transcripts that are
observed across one or more of those
fluids
um but there are often things that are
unique so when we have partners that
come to us and say i'm working
in plasma but i want to try it in urine
um we often
can say there's a very good chance that
that will
uh um that your gene will be detected
in plasma or urine but we won't know
because there are still things that are
unique
um so we will always investigate to see
but there's a very good chance
and so gene detection is only part of
the story the other is the gene
expression profile and so that's what
this pca plot here on the right
is demonstrating and so
the structure and where these uh
biofluids separate to
or or overlap is driven by the
expression
um of these genes that are detected here
so not surprisingly
plasma and serum essentially being the
same or very similar biofluid
compartment overlap
as you might anticipate whereas csf and
urine separate from
from blood
and so what does what do we do
with these uh
um with the patterns that we see with
the biomarkers that we
um identify when using the
rna-seq pipeline we would then take that
focus and make a targeted approach
for example here this example is
targeting
mutations in variants that are prevalent
in lung cancer and we would then use
uh for example qpcr to target and refine
uh for a translational or a clinical
assay
um we could also apply other uh
platforms
and so i won't go into i won't go into
the specifics of
what was uh um the
methodology for deciding what the
targets were gonna be but needless to
say this is a qpcr assay
targeting prevalent uh fusion variants
that capture
a majority of lung cancer uh variants
and this is uh an illustration of what a
very typical assay workflow
for an exosomal sample would look like
anywhere from one to four mls of plasma
so
very amenable very low
input needs through our proprietary
extraction technology
uh rt and qpcr for
targets of interest uh leading to a
diagnostic result
and basically as you might uh uh
expect to see here where uh you're
looking for alk-positive here we did a
comparison against
samples that were orthogonally validated
by
tissue fish status to
have alk rearrangements and then we can
detect
uh those alk rearrangements as positive
alk readouts
uh in those plasma samples as well
and so one of the things that's very new
and super exciting for us that exosome
is a is a recent partnership
um that we press released with uh
kyogen and so we've had a relationship
running with kaiogen for
a many for many years but we've just
expanded upon that
um and it's it's very exciting for both
of us to be able to be doing that and so
what does that mean to you as partners
with biotechne and exosome and
what what that really means is it's
enabling kyogen's
global scale and and reinforce
reimbursement experience
as well as their facilities and their
experience
in sample extraction as well as all
these other
uh expertises that we share with them
to quickly develop uh and support
exosome based liquid biopsy
uh for your cdx needs
and before i um hand uh the
the microphone over to my colleague dr
chris bunker
i'll just mention uh briefly that while
i focused on things that were around
qpcr
or our ngs uh rna-seq we at x's home do
a
a lot of different exosome based
research programs including supporting
other biotechni
uh platforms and so with that
i will gladly turn this over to
dr chris bunker hello my name is chris
bunker and today i will speak about the
rna scope in situ hybridization assay
technology
of advanced cell diagnostics which is a
brand of biotechne
like the exosome diagnostics platform
that you just heard about
rna scope is another way in which to
expand the options and means
of biomarker analysis and potential
companion diagnostics
the rna scope is an intentional
hybridization
biomarker assay platform that like pcr
it has very high levels of specificity
and sensitivity for
mrna detection unlike pcr it works on
routine formula effects parameter
tissues that makes it similar to hc and
it has a similar workflow however
in this case we're hybridizing with
oligonucleotides that are
sequence specific for a biomarker mrna
and signal amplification occurs locally
so that the
signal that we detect is corresponds to
individual molecules of mrna which can
be quantified
with spatial resolution rna scope is a
very robust method for
mrna biomarker detection in fixed
tissues because of the probe design
as mentioned signal amplification is
dependent on pairs of oligonucleotides
hybridizing immediately adjacent to each
other
to short sequences about 40 to 50
nucleotides
each pair enable enables signal
amplification so like pcr
signal is is dependent on pairs of
oligonucleotides hybridizing
but in this case we use a very large
number of oligos tiled along a region
of the target mrna
however we only need a few of these
pairs to bind to generate detectable
signal
this built-in redundancy is what makes
it so effective and reliable
in detecting rna biomarkers in fixed
tissues
eventual diagnostics has two in-situ
hybridization acid technologies
one is rna scope the other is base scope
rna scope is
the perhaps more robust assay in that
it's been
in use for about 10 years now it enables
higher levels of plexing three four plex
assays on formal and fixed issues and
even higher plex assays on frozen
tissues
it is also actually being used for
diagnostic purposes currently
in particular for hpv detection in head
and neck cancer
bayscope is an assay which we use for
specific applications
specific biomarkers where rna scope
would not be
suitable or not able to differentiate
the intended target from
non-targets in particular bayscope is
used for
detection of splice variants for
instance fgfr
2b and 2c variants it can be used to
look at fusion junctions
you can also detect specifically target
sequences that are members of highly
complex gene families moreover it can be
used for point mutation detection
and also illustrations of that as well
this slide is from the first publication
with the rna scope assay and simply is
to
demonstrate the the fact that what we
detect with rna scope
as dots visual dots correspond to
individual molecules of rna
this is a simple cell culture experiment
where hela cells were tested
with an rna scope probe to her2 on the
left-hand side you can see
visual green dots and there are
approximately 14
dots per cell in a field of view in
comparison
another plate of helo cells had rna
extracted
and measured in solution with a standard
curve of in vitro transcribe message
in that way an average value of 17
copies of of her2 rna could be measured
on a per cell basis and so these two
numbers 17 copies per cell on average
from a lysate and 14 dots per cell
are very similar and this is to show
that
an individual molecule is being detected
when we see dots
in a fixed cell or fixed tissue
this assay was used by the lab of the
late ray tubbs at the cleveland clinic
as a means of differentiating or
resolving i should say
cases where her2 status was equivocal
based on either ihc or or dna fish
what uh the rate the lab of ray tubbs
did
was to measure her to transcript level
in breast cancer
and determine a molecular threshold that
corresponded to her2 positivity
in comparison to ihc this is a bit of a
busy
uh figure but the the primary point here
is that
using a molecular cutoff of her2
measured
by rna scope in the first place they can
show
a very good concordance between cases
where
ihc is equivocal but fish is negative
for her2 amplification
and rna scope signal is also negative in
the middle
you're seeing cases where ihc again is
equivocal
but it's fish positive for amplification
of the her2 locus
and likewise her2 transcript levels are
also amplified above that molecular
threshold
the important uh data set was in cases
where both ihc
and fish were equivocal and could not uh
firmly establish the
the role of her2 in in breast cancer
in this case what's shown is the same
molecular cutoff can be used to
define a patient as being positive above
the threshold or negative
below that threshold so this is just a
point about the
ability to use molecular quantification
of a
transcript in this case her2 to define
a patient as being positive or negative
and potentially responsive to
a targeted therapeutic this in the next
few slides will show examples where rna
scope was determined to be more
sensitive and specific than
other methods for measuring uh specific
biomarkers that were
a predictive or appear to be predictive
of patient response to
an oncology targeted therapeutic the
example shown here is for
merrimack pharmaceuticals mm-121 anti or
b3 therapeutic
where they determined that it was
actually the ligand growth factor
hergulin
or nrg1 which was a predictive or at
least correlated with response to
their therapeutic m120 mn121
now the fact that nrg1 is a growth
factor and secreted
excreted protein made it very difficult
to detect it by ihc
in intact tissue biopsies and the fact
that they were getting
very small needle biopsies from the
patient
did not provide them with sufficient
material material to get a reliable
qpcr readout moreover the spatial
resolution
of the rna scope assay enabled them to
verify
the presence of heregolan expression in
the tumor itself as opposed to in
adjacent stromal cells and these factors
contributed to its utility
as a potential biomarker assay
shown here is retrospective data from
phase one clinical trials in breast
cancer ovarian cancer and lung cancer
where
they observe that high levels of
irregulin as measured by
the rna scope assay appeared to identify
a sub-population of patients which were
responsive and showed longer
progression-free survival
in comparison to patients with low
heregulan expression
it was based on these results that they
used this assay as the basis for patient
selection
in in a phase ii clinical trial
rna scope also proved to be a very
effective biomarker assay for
bears fgfr one two and three small
molecule tyrosine kinase inhibitor
in this case it showed superior
performance compared to
ihc and nanostring and the starting
point for this was the fact that
historically
gene amplification and genomic
alterations of fgfr
genes has been used as a way to identify
patients for um
for small molecule tyrosine kinase
inhibitors however uh published reports
show that
there actually was not a very good
correlation between uh tki sensitivity
uh and gene amplification and in fact
expression was a better predictor and
based on these results they used the rna
scope assay for
as a basis for enrollment in their phase
one clinical trial
as well as their phase two clinical
trials in both cases both clinical
trials
there was a very uh high rate of
response to
their tyrosine kinase inhibitor in
patients that were selected with the rna
scope assay
and this isn't just in one illustration
here a case where there was no genomic
alteration
in this patient's biopsy uh however
there was
a significant increase in fgfr rna
expression
and this patient did in fact respond
very well to
treatment this was observed in a very
large percentage of the patients that
were enrolled in this trial
the idea one checkpoint target is
another
good illustration of where methods like
rna scope
can be more effective than more
well-established
approaches like ihc in oncology
ihc is probably the default method that
people think about when they think about
a biomarker assay however
oftentimes it will be the case that
newer assays like rna scope as well as
exosome diagnostic assays may be more
effective
and will certainly be much more time
efficient and cost effective to develop
i mention this headline here
to just to illustrate this point which
is that
it was about three years of time spent
uh by
insight with roche montana to try to
develop an ihc assay which
in the end in the end was shown to be
about 10 times less sensitive than the
rna scope assay for measurement of ido1
expression
what's shown here is cell culture work
on helo cells where
interferon gamma can be used to induce
id1 expression
and what was observed was that in a dose
response to
interferon gamma treatment both western
blot
and rna scope were able to detect id1
expression
at a 10 times lower dose of interference
gamma
indicating a greater sensitivity so
while rna and protein
correlate very well with one another in
an assay
of intact cells or tissues
the rna scope assay was proven to be
more
more sensitive than ihc and as a result
of this
they went on to use rna scope in
collaboration with acd
in multiple phase 1 and phase 2 and
phase 3 clinical trials testing
well over 2 500 patients again it was
unfortunate certainly that
the drug proved not to be very
efficacious however from a technical
standpoint the
the results showed that the rna scope
assay was a very robust and reliable
method of biomarker analysis
for this particular biomarker another
example for
an ongoing clinical trial with leap
therapeutics where
their anti-dkk-1 antibody is being
tested in patients
where dkk-1 expression is being measured
by rna scope
here like in the case of miramax mm121
therapeutic
the target is a secreted protein and so
measurement of that by ihc
is not very effective whereas measuring
expression of the dkk1 transcript
and identifying the cell populations
expressing that is something which can
be provided with the rna scope assay
and here like with heregolin high levels
of
dk.com1 expression identified a patient
population with a
higher probability of long-term survival
compared to those patients that had a
low dkk one expression
so this is an ongoing clinical trial
phase two clinical trial and and could
lead to
uh companion diagnostic development here
is an illustration of our base scope
rna and situation assay showing
detection of
egfr point mutations namely t7idm
as well as l858r now
in the previous slides i showed examples
of our rna scope assay for measurement
of expression biomarkers and often times
with gene expression
particularly in the case of oncology
it's important to understand
what cell types or regions within the
tumor microenvironment
are expressing that biomarker and that's
something which comes from
in situ analysis which gives you
morphological context
oftentimes in the case of mutations the
mutation itself is
is indicative or diagnostic of a
uh of an of an oncogene being active and
that can be measured
either by institute hybridization as
shown here
or by methods like the exosome
diagnostic approach and here
again just illustrating the fact that we
can in fact detect point mutations and
measure
point mutation expression in intact
tissues
this type of assay could provide a
bridge to a liquid biopsy assay such as
that of
exosome dx using the two assays to show
correlation between
analysis and tissue and analysis in a
liquid biopsy
like likewise for alk or the anaplastic
lymphoma kinase as was shown in previous
slides
fusions which are activating mutations
of alk can be measured by pcr from
exosomes
here we're showing measurement of
overexpression of alk by rna scope
overexpression being the result of
fusion to various different
various different genes so here again
like with egfr
and other mutations it may be useful to
use the rna scope method
and exosome analysis to
cross confirm and and verify whether or
not a liquid biopsy approach will be is
also suitable however again uh if there
is a reason to think or if there is data
supporting the fact that there's
information in spatial resolution or
in in morphological analysis of a
mutation such as this or or egfr
that's where an rna scope or base
capacity can be applied to
provide a spatial resolution of
expression patterns or mutations
so our assays like those of exosome dx
exosome vx has a partner in kaiogen we
have a partner
in leica biosystems for companion
diagnostic development
this is enabled by the fact that assay
is being run in a research setting where
biomarker asks can be developed work
on their research use only instrument
their bond rx
and those can be easily ported over to
and
and validated for use in a diagnostic
setting on their diagnostic bond 3
instrument
we would make a case obviously being
somewhat biased
towards the rna scope assay that there
are many advantages and
and benefits to the rna scope approach
compared to other methodologies
in particular we do emphasize the
importance
and value in analysis of biomarkers
within the morphological context and
having spatial resolution
of what cell types and regions within a
tissue
expression is being observed that's
something which is obtained both from
rna scope and ihc
but not extraction-based methods like
qpcr
or or ngs the assay with rna scope is
is oftentimes much more sensitive than
than similar
tissue based methods like ihc has
comparable sensitivity to
extraction-based methods like
ngs or qpcr likewise specificity is very
very high
with our molecular analysis with rna
scope and those
other extraction-based methods a benefit
a potential
relevance to clinical analysis is the
fact that the rna scope assay requires
very minimal tissue just a few five
micron sections
oftentimes methods that are based on
extraction of nucleic acids require
a larger amount of material
so overall what we have to offer with
the rna scope assay as well as base
scope
are are are assays and probes that can
be used to detect virtually any target
or biomarker
the illustration with ideo1 in relation
to the ihc assay
that was attempted in that case is the
fact that we can develop probes and
assays very very quickly
these assays can also be multiplexed
with cell markers
or multiple targets where that's
relevant and again the benefit of
nucleic acid based assay is it is
very highly sensitive and um and
quantifiable
on a per cell basis in summary what we
have presented today
are two biomarker platforms of the
biotechnic corporation
one the exosome platform of exosome
diagnostics and the other
the rna scope platform of advanced cell
diagnostics
both of these have advantages of very
high specificity and sensitivity that
are inherent to nucleic acid-based tests
in addition the exosome platform offers
the advantage of being
a liquid biopsy based test and the rna
scope platform offers advantage of
spatial resolution in the context of
intact tissue morphology
both assay platforms are easily
implemented and
with our partnerships with kaiogen in
the case of exosome diagnostics
and leica biosystems in the case of
advanced cell diagnostics
both have a straightforward and clear
path for companion diagnostic
development with these factors in mind
we hope that you will consider
inclusion of exosome diagnostics and
rna scope in your clinical biomarker
strategies
thank you very much
thank you dr monroe dr bunker and dr
valentino for your informative
presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question
asks how our exosome liquid biopsy
biomarkers
validated as compared to solid tumor
markers
thanks uh kylie this is mike
valentino from exome diagnostics and
um that's a great question uh i think
actually the way we would approach uh
validation is really similar to how
other people may be familiar with tumor
solid tumor marker validation
it's not all that different and the way
that we think about it
is kind of twofold so if
in our very broad for example
rna-seq-based approach you identify some
biomarkers that are really interesting
and relevant
um but often you don't know what that's
going to look like in a broader
patient cohort larger demographic uh
and and really want to ask additional
questions as to the utility and validity
in the clinical sense for those
biomarkers we would
uh develop a more targeted approach
whether it be ngs or two pcr-based
panels
to take those preliminary biomarkers and
validate them forward
in terms of their utility uh
and usability in uh your
clinical space and once you go through
and you
you uh validate those markers and that
holds up
uh in your patient demographics
we then would actually validate the
assay itself
and so there's a couple of ways that you
look to do that analytical validation
and uh we're well uh burst in in doing
that
both for our own programs and for our uh
programs that we run together with our
partners um
and uh you know basically uh starting in
the one setting and then moving it into
our
clia diagnostics
facilities in order to support the
analytically validated clinical assays
great thank you our next question here
asks
can you look at dna or proteins along
with rna
kaley this is uh mikey and i'll i'll
dive in on this first
um exosomes are actually a really uh
powerful robust resource for
liquid biopsy and for investigation and
so um
as i kind of alluded to um on the
slides today we focused on rna but we do
other things as well like protein so
just like
the rna based cargo within exosomes
there are also protein carbons both
was contained within and embedded on the
surface of the exosomes
and so we have programs uh that are
focusing on
exosomal based proteins and dna is
another thing that
that can also be captured and carried
along with
the rna cargo as well and i didn't at
all touch upon this today but we at
exodom also have a proprietary
column isolation approach that captures
cell-free
dna and this is this is basically
analogous to any of the cell
free dna approaches that others
uh support uh where the dna fragments
are actually not
uh um
contained within exosomes these are
actually free-floating
soluble uh dna fragments and so we have
a column approach that can
capture with uh the same
uh performance as other gold standard
cfdna
kits uh rna from exosomes as well as
cfdna in a single one-step
isolation which has been very very
powerful
especially for mutation detection
i might this is chris bunker from acdl
i'll add
just a brief point regarding a detection
of various
um types of molecules in the context of
rna scope assays
um we actually do a great deal of work
uh combining ihc or amino fluorescence
with rna scope
uh oftentimes using um either ic or
amino fluorescence for for cell marker
detection
um in particular immune cell markers so
um
combination of of a protein-based
detection
alongside rna scope for mrna detection
that that's something we do routinely
we are developing methods so-called dna
scope methods for
doing dna detection similar to rna scope
but
those will likely be completely separate
assays from
from rna detection
awesome all right we'll go to our next
question here which asks
what are some applications that can be
or have been supported
beyond oncology biomarkers
maybe i'll start with that this is
against chris bunker actually a really
important area for us
um in use of the rna scope assay is
uh in looking at kind of more
pharmacodynamic or pharmacokinetic
markers again in the context of
oncology we use rna-scope probes to
detect
engineered cell therapeutics car t cells
and tcrt cells
by targeting viral sequences that are
present in most of those cell
therapeutics
and so that provides us with a means of
monitoring and quantifying
the infiltration into a tumor of of cell
therapy
like car t cells and likewise
oftentimes we combine with those assays
or other
immuno immuno oncology related assays
the measurement of cytokines and
chemokines
like the assays i showed for looking at
tkk1 and regulin
assays of cytokines and other secreted
factors that are
indicators of immune cell activity are
very effectively performed with rna
scope or we're looking at the rna
and the cell type producing that rna
yeah that's that's great um chris i
think
i think what is awesome between the acd
rna scope technology and what we at x
zone can do
a lot of what chris just covered is is
really how we think about it
at exosome as well how we apply it
uh in our programs and and kind of one
of the
the main things for us in a liquid
biopsy based approach
compared to other modalities for liquid
biopsy investigation
is that because we're looking at these
rna
profiles you're able to
capture exosomes in both normal and
disease settings and we're not
tracking only mutant molecules uh
like you like you would be kind of stuck
with with
other ctc based approaches or ct dna
based approaches where you're only
tracking mutant molecules as
as uh signals for your
uh your disease and so we
uh span well beyond oncology we have
active
programs in neuro and
many other io approaches as well
um really owing to the fact that it's
rna
and tracking rna expression differences
and not really just built on
polymorphisms and mutant tracking
great all right it looks like we have
time for a few more questions
this next one says how can exosome and
rna scope assays be used in
pharmacodynamic studies
i guess i already sort of answered that
one um so maybe mike you can
add to that yeah and i think
again it's very similar and that this is
why they're
they're really two great and
complementary approaches i think is it
is is really i think the way um chris
captured it is
kind of how we would do but also just in
a liquid biopsy based setting
great all right so we have time for one
last question here and
this one says how can you or excuse me
how do you validate
single copy detection
uh i'll um i'll sort of dive in on this
so
a single single copy detection and
validating in an analytical sense
is uh can often be uh challenging
but when we uh strive to
analytically validate or even just
benchmark performance
we often will take advantage of uh
samples that are available either from
um
sample repository uh sources or anything
that you guys
that our partners may have in their uh
biobanks
that we can take advantage of to explore
uh
for detection but also we take advantage
of synthetic molecules
uh either at the the rna level or the
dna level
and we can do spike in experiments and
recovery experiments
uh into complex matrices like
plasma serum csf urine any any uh
biofluid that you're looking at to be
able to within the
complexities of your matrix of interest
uh
really get a refined uh
performance specification uh
of the the assays we that we design
in the case of arnie scope um
to a similar extent we we rely on uh
comparison to
methods like ppcr or
rna sequencing or and also as well as
nanostring assays to
to show concordance between what we can
quantify an intact issue by counting
dots with what can be counted
in an extracted sample where it's easier
to use
spikens as mike mentioned and other ways
to
establish a standard curve and and many
times over very repeatably
we can show the ability to detect and
quantify
individual molecules of nucleic acid in
particular mrna
great all right well i want to remind
our audience that those
um with questions who we were unable to
answer today
um that those come in during the
on-demand period
will be answered by nicholas via the
email address you provided at the time
of registration
so thank you again dr monroe dr bunker
and dr valentino do you have any final
comments for our audience
no final comments just wanted to thank
everyone for joining us today
please feel free to reach out with any
questions about the technologies or
your interests in companion diagnostic
development with exosome diagnostics or
advanced cell diagnostics
thank you very much
all right before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
monroe dr bunker and dr valentino for
their time today
and their important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor advanced cell diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
that's all for now until next time
goodbye